hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel
learning a new programming language
would be a hassle unless you have a
clear learning path to it similarly java
java is one of the highly demanded
programming languages in the current iit
industry also it is one of the most
sophisticated languages to excel in such
a language you would definitely need a
planned learning path today's session
will be all about the tips to learn java
in a faster and effective manner
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you're a tech geek in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our channel and
hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply done now without
further ado let's get started with the
important tips to learn java programming
language
so the first one is getting started with
the basic fundamentals followed by that
we should be strong with algorithms and
flowcharts next start coding from
scratch later understand what exactly is
debugging and finally try some simple
projects and stay updated now let us
understand each one of them in detail so
the first one is basic terminologies
data types variables operators logical
functions and conditional statements are
building blocks of any programming
language this is the best place to get
started with java you can find tons of
resources online that could help you
with the fundamentals absolutely for
free of cost the core java tutorial from
simply learn could prove to be a good
resource to kick start your java
learning path the link to the video will
be provided in the description box below
the second important step is to learn
the algorithms and flowcharts you might
be wondering if algorithms and
flowcharts are just visual
representations of the logic behind the
code not just you but every beginner
ends up with the same picture but did
you know that algorithms and flowcharts
is where the solution actually starts to
take shape yes the algorithms and
flowcharts are used to design a solution
to explain step-by-step approach of the
solution to the problem if the solution
is potentially feasible then you can get
started with coding the solution so you
must be capable of setting your
algorithms and flowcharts carefully
prior to getting started with code i'll
link a full tutorial on algorithms and
data structures to better help you with
everything at one place followed by
algorithms we have our test trials that
is start coding from scratch after you
are comfortable with the basics
algorithms and flow charts it is time
you try implementing them by writing
actual code trust me at this point most
of you might face trouble implementing
the logic using code if you face any
such issue it is better you turn back to
the drawing board and learn the basics
of programming again it won't cost you
much time compared to the time you would
waste in the future trying to crack
higher level logics as they might seem
more complicated than they actually are
now the next step yes to all those who
are wondering now it's time to get
started with a fully fledged project let
me hold your horses there because there
is one sensitive and critical step left
behind between the learning to code
stage and programming a fully fledged
project it is called debugging you might
be thinking the compiler does it but
there is a gigantic difference between
translating the code to execute and
debug the code
it's simple your logic for the code
could be correct but not perfect in a
few situations for example let us
presume that you are a beginner and you
are told to write a code for division
operation
let us imagine that you have written a
code with three variables a dividend b
divisor and c is equals to result that
is c is equals to a divided by b now
your code might work in ideal situations
where the divisor is less than the
dividend and the divisor is not zero but
in case the divisor is zero or the
dividend is smaller than the divisor
then you might see your code getting
compromised here you need to make minor
twists and turns to your code and
implement exception handling to resolve
the situation by throwing an exception
to the user instead of throwing an error
in runtime
finally improvising and optimizing the
code logic i'll link down the tutorial
for exception handling in java so you
have a better understanding of the same
now
you know your next step a fully fledged
project there are many projects
available on online as open source and
you can also get started with your own
ideas creating a fully fledged project
will put your skills to test and open a
window to learn new things that you
might have missed in the learning phase
there are multiple java project videos
by simply learn i'll have the end to end
project build tutorials and the top 10
java projects that can get you hired
links in the description box below now
the final step stay updated it's a fact
that major programming languages ides
and frameworks roll out new updates
every month every quarter every year or
even after a few years no matter what to
be competent in the industry you have to
stay updated so you have to be
constantly checking out for new updates
and try to up skill in time simply learn
is always dedicated to help and guide
passionate learners in the right way so
we have come up with skill up where you
can get your dream certification with
industry standards at free of cost yes
you heard me right for free i'll leave
the link to the simply learn skill up
free java certification in the
description box below feel free to check
it out with that we have come to an end
of this session on tips to learn java if
you have found the tutorial to be
helpful please leave us a like and if
you find that we have missed out on some
important suggestions then please feel
free to let us know in the comment
section below as they might help the
others as well until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here